let's get started
uh all right so some people say that we
are all here
let's get started okay uh indeed uh
so let's get started it's uh
our pleasure to have uh stefan zhang uh
who is a lead research scientist at uh
salesforce uh to
give us a presentation about uh their
recent work
uh about ai economist uh
so uh stefan
um uh focuses on deep reinforcement
learning and simulation based learning
and as as the talk shows this is done
for designing
economic policies uh he holds a phd in
physics from
car tech and intern twice
with google and
his research covered during his phd
imitation learning for long-term
planning
basketball and exciting stuff
neural network robustness amongst others
before machine learning he studied
mathematics and theoretical physics
the university of cambridge harvard
university and
utrecht university and he received the
lorenz graduation prize
uh from the royal netherlands academy of
arts and sciences for his master's
studies
on exotic dualities in topological
string theory
and was twice awarded the dutch national
eugene's
scholarship so it's a great pleasure to
have you
stefan here uh we're looking forward to
your talk
uh thanks sabah thanks so much for that
kind of intro
and thanks so much everyone for
organizing this event
it's uh really awesome i listen to ms
talk
really interesting stuff and i'm very
happy to
present the ai economist here today
which is a team
effort with a lot of great people here
that you can see
and hopefully i will talk about some of
the exciting results that we've found
so in a nutshell this research
is trying to simulate an economy
millions of times over
to create fair tax policy and from a
technical point of view
we're trying to do two-level
reinforcement learning
for adaptive policy design
and altogether at a very high level we
hope that this is a first step towards
evaluating policies
in eai simulations to make future policy
making less ideological more data driven
and the reason we are taking this ai
approach is
basically that economists and policy
makers today
try to improve economic outcomes but
often their tools are
very limited so data is an issue
economic data there might just be not
enough of it
secondly if we look at traditional
economics they often use very simple
reductive models of
people companies governments and other
institutions
and thirdly it's really hard to
experiment in the real world so
we cannot run to parallel versions of
the united states just to see
what a control group does as opposed to
some other
policy that we might propose
and in particular if we look at the
world one big motivation for us
is that one of the biggest
socio-economic problems today
is economic inequality so if we look at
the
incomes in the u.s historically
the top 1 percent has seen the income
grow much
faster than the bottom 20 percent and
this is actually a global trend
as you can see on the right now here
inequality just means how much the
incomes
per year differ between different
workers in the economy
and productivity is just the sum of all
the incomes and we can see that this gap
is growing and there are many many
downstream effects
negative downstream effects because of
this which are well documented
and so taxes are a key government tool
to improve
equality and to minimize the harm that
these downstream effects can cause
but this is actually a very hard
optimization problem
so you can use taxes to transfer wealth
from the rich to the poor
but at the same time if you do that too
much then taxes can discourage work
and decrease overall productivity so if
you plot equality
and productivity in this two-dimensional
plot here
then there's this pareto boundary where
beyond which you cannot improve one
without hurting the other
and in this work we basically look at
four different ways of setting taxes
such that we get first of all as close
as possible to the pre to boundary
and hopefully we can also control the
point on the boundary that it that we
end up with
and this is a really hard problem um
and if we look at the
his history of tax theory um
the seminal work in 1927 basically
provided one of the first mathematical
treatments of
how you should set optimal taxes to
balance uh these forces in the economy
and this was written by ramsey it was
named a contribution to the fear of
taxation quite a humble title
but it's actually considered a seminal
work in that literature
and the way we um the way that paper
tries to solve the problem is that
it tries to max my social welfare which
we can think of as the
sum of all the rewards of the agents in
the economy
and these agents are in some market and
then the government tries to raise a
certain amount of tax
and what ramsay showed is that if you
make some approximations for instance
you can assume that the
utility of every agent is locally
quadratic
then you can actually derive explicit
tax formulas
so here utility we can think of it as
the reward that an
agent experiences and the key point that
ramsey showed is that
taxes should be inversely proportional
to the elasticity
elasticity means how sensitive how
people are
to a change in the tax rate then in 1971
and 2001 there
has been more theoretical work where
people try to get away from these
uh sort of linearization assumptions
and uh you know so there's non-linear
taxation and
in particular the assumption that people
make there is that people have different
skills
so people make different amount of money
per hour depending on the quality and
the the difficulty of the job they do
and what they showed is that you can
actually derive optional non-linear
tax formulas and again the the property
of these formulas are is that they are
proportional to the inverse of this
elasticity
the limitation though is that they
typically limit themselves to a single
task period so it's
like a banded setting if you will and
the econ is quite static so everyone is
an equilibrium like a natural
equilibrium
an analog of natural deworming
and then very recently and in past 10 20
years
in economics people have also started
looking at dynamic sequential economies
in particular the new dynamic public
finance um you know by golo soft and
cochlear coda
um consider the sequential setting so
this is closer to the
mdp setting in rl and also there's
something called the dynamics of cacio
general equilibrium models
and these models basically look at
shocks like recessions
or education where people might increase
their skill by going to school
and other effects that like you know
like investing or you know interest
rates
and what you see in this is this broad
trend that
in 1927 people had simple models and you
could derive clubs from solutions
but as you go to these dynamic
sequential settings
for these complex economies are actually
very few analytical solutions
and explicit tax formulas uh you know
that you can derive
and this is where we try to use
reinforcing learning instead
to have a data driven solution
so i can pause here for just a second to
see if there's any questions
um and i'm not sure if
i'm happy to take questions in between
or i can just go um
i think as i will try to monitor the
questions
um so far so good i think
no questions so far okay great
so so the the point of this work is that
we want to try to take a
reinforcement learning approach to this
optimal taxation problem
and there are two ingredients uh
simulation and reinforcement learning so
i'll first talk about the economic
simulation we built for this problem
so here it is so we see this
two-dimensional top-down view of the
spatial world
and we have four agents here that are
running around
they are gathering resources like stone
and wood and then they build houses
and building houses gives you money so
you can see the orange guy in the middle
is building a lot of houses in the
middle and then
the dark blue asian in the bottom left
for instance is
walking over these trees and stone that
yields resources
and then he also built some houses and
at the same time
that agent could also decide to sell
those resources to the other agents
so that's the reason this orange agent
can build a lot of houses even though
he's not actually picking up
a lot of resources himself
and at the same time there's also a
government
controlled ai economist that will set
income taxes and subsidize agents
you know transferring wealth that it
gains through these taxes
now the the simulation actually
has a number of low-level details that
are important to
uh talk about uh so for instance
these resources will stochastically
respond and empty source tiles and
there's some fixed probability
uh that you know yields within stone
and then secondly uh all these
activities that these agents can do like
moving around gathering resources and
building houses will actually cost some
amount of
labor some amount of effort so for
instance
if i move on tile it cost me 0.21
in some unit of labor
secondly there's a trading mechanism so
this works
kind of like a commodity exchange or
stock stock exchange if you will
so every agent can buy and sell
resources by submitting a best bid on
ask
to the to the exchange and then there's
some market
mechanism that determines how bidders
and
bidders and askers can get paired up and
again
if you place an order this will cost you
a small amount of labor
it's less than moving around because
sitting around your computer and trading
is not as
intense and thirdly
these agents can build houses so an
agent can turn one wood and one stone
into a house
that creates a house tile on the map and
then
this actually gives you a lot of money
but the amount of money that you get
actually depends on how good you are at
building it so there's a building skill
a number that you can think of as the
hourly wage or
the the pay that the agent gets for
building that house
and at the same time building does cost
a large amount of labor
at 2.1 so it's 10 times as expensive as
moving around
now together these numbers feed into
how happy these agents are
with the money that they earn uh so
here's
a breakdown plot there's a lot of a lot
going on here
so in the top row we can see a movie
wheel of the
simulation that i showed you before not
exactly the same one but something
similar
and in the middle world you can see how
much each agent worked
how much money they accumulated and how
much utility that your
agent experienced over time so each
episode here takes 1 000 time steps
and then there are four agents orange
yellow and then
light and dark blue and you can see that
if we look at the
happiness of each agent as
each agent makes more money it also has
to work more
and so there's this law of diminishing
returns which basically models the idea
that
uh just like in real life you might work
on weekends to earn more money
but the effort might actually not be
worth it to you right there's this
diminishing uh utility that you get from
an extra money
and i'll show you these explicit
formulas later but the the
crucial part here is is that there's
this medicine
returns what that leads to
is emergent specialization because of
this
loft emission returns some agents
actually see that it's not really worth
it to them to build a lot of houses
but instead it's actually more
profitable in terms of utility
to sell their resources so we see that
one of the
interesting uh emerging phenomena from
the from this is is that if you
have reinforcement learning agents in
this simulation and they maximize
utility
specialization emerges
and this is also apparent in the bottom
so if we look at the third row
we can see how much was traded
in this economy and positive bars here
means that
that particular agent sold a resource
and received money
negative bars mean that the agent
actually paid money so he lost money but
he got gained a resource
and we see that in his picture the
fourth agent the one
all the way to the right actually spent
a lot of money to buy a lot of resources
and all the other agents mainly sold
visas to that agent okay
we do have some questions uh
so thomas gilbert asks
can you discuss justify some of the
assumptions behind the simulation they
seem a bit unrealistic
market economies have not existed for
millions of years
in fact badly for five generations
people do not
in fact build houses to make money at
saturn
so i guess uh yeah the question is uh
how did you decide about the rules of
this simulation
uh what were you trying to incorporate
and uh how did you do this
yeah that's a really great question um
so for us
there's two objectives we want to show
that we
satisfy the basic modeling
features or model features of an economy
as is discussed in the optimal taxation
literature
so that means that you need some uh just
like ramsey there needs to be some sort
of mechanism by which
uh first of all agents can earn money
and secondly these agents need to
interact with each other in some way
so i need to be able to trade with you
for instance right and this
uh make sure that resources are
allocated efficiently in this world
so the way we chose these particular
ingredients and put them together is
that it's sort of the minimal
set of features and economy such that
you can study this trade-off that people
study in optimal taxation
but you're right that you know it's not
it's not the real one
yeah yeah my understanding was that you
you try to
come up with a simplified setting which
are
somewhat realistic uh like uh
maybe the amount of uh
goods like there is replenishment of
resources but
but that's all that's the input to the
system that
makes it grow i guess or sustain itself
uh but for example agents are not
printing money or anything like that
uh right that's right
so okay um
so another question is what utility
function is assumed for agents
in the model my related question was uh
what information was available to the
agents
because you said that these are
reinforcement learning agents so they
are optimizing their utility
it must be based on some observations
that they have about like
the whole state of the economy and
my question was uh perhaps related to
this other one
what is the information and then what is
the utility function that they are
optimizing yeah uh i i will give you all
the details in a couple slides down the
line
uh if it mean basically uh in a nutshell
the utility function
is a power law um over
post-tax income and the observation
is uh local so the agent can see
a small neighborhood around itself you
can see tax rates and
you know see how much it owns but not so
much what other agents own and so on so
but yeah there's no like global
information not much global information
regarding uh so there was this question
about that
millions of years whatnot uh so how do
you
respond to that uh uh that that is
simulation i
assume that the question refers to that
here the simulation needs to last
for many many i don't know simulated
years
um which is not realistic uh
but but i guess maybe there is an answer
to that
yeah um i guess in particular we chose
1000 here
together with the coefficients for the
utility functions such that every agent
can experience
a maximal utility so at some point the
agents
decide to stop working so to say in
these simulations
but you're right that you could have
more time steps if you wanted to or a
more streaming version of utility there
are many possibilities
that's true i would have imagined that
you would say that
uh in the river there is a lot of power
assimilation going on so many more
people than
the number of so what was the number of
agent that you used in this simulated
economy
so here are four yeah so
i think that like you can trade off
between you know learning speed and like
people are spreading information
teaching each other you can parallelize
a lot of this learning if you have
lots of agents and then they're kind of
spreading information about what
strategies work what
doesn't work and of course you you are
in a simplified setting and
uh therefore your time span is going to
be larger but your
spatial span is much smaller uh
so there's a trade-off that you chose uh
but i guess
uh yeah like uh from the perspective of
the conclusions you want to reach or
like the hypothesis you want to examine
this
probably shouldn't matter that much i
don't know
what do you say no i think that's right
so for us this particular setup all the
choices we make
are basically to demonstrate that two
level reinforcement learning is a very
powerful optimization technique
that takes adaptive adaptability and
strategic behavior of these agents into
account
and the the choice of utilities and and
other features of the economy in some
sense are
just there to make sure that we see that
trade-off between equality and
productivity in the economy
um so we we don't claim that this
economic simulation is necessarily like
the real world
it's more so a vehicle for us to
demonstrate uh the potential of this
reinforced morning approach
and and and also like that what kind of
trade-ups
uh even a simple model like this
leads to uh there was another question
that was related to the very first one
by sven hotkenstein uh
could you play 5i to use this wood and
stone economy
you mentioned the dsge models which
based their structure parameters and
empirical findings which still is quite
a tough to exactly identify those
parameters mapping to deep behavioral
parameters of agents
on which basis do you access your
parameters driving productivity of your
agents
i guess you sort of um answer this uh
question
uh uh if i understood the question
correctly
how do we choose the parameters it was
just to show
uh let every agent experience some the
max
of their utility curve within this
episode and
i guess i guess maybe the point of the
question was that economists have been
really busy trying to fit models
uh to the real world and uh
those are usually really hard to feed
they have many parameters
uh and then you come with this like
simplified setting compared to maybe of
some of these
economic models uh and why did you
choose
this as opposed to something that is out
there in the literature
but i guess like we discussed because
your purpose is is a little bit
different you're not trying to model
the real world here that was not your
point right
that's right yeah it's more like a study
of like
like hey let's understand what this
could lead to
uh what insights could we gain uh i
don't know like i'm just
uh trying to unders yeah okay
um and uh the last question does
uh specialization emerge from some
comparative advantages and towed
on the agents or is it just an outcome
from trading
it's definitely a related to trading
the trading gives the uh agents
optionality
they can either build or they can sell
right and that's what the rl asian
experiences and and
you know some asians decide to just sell
and other agents decide to build a lot
i'm also guessing that it's also
necessary for the agents to have
different skill levels or
uh or maybe have you tried the
simulation when all the agents were
homogeneous and then
the question is whether in that case uh
specialization would arise maybe it
would right
uh you know
yeah it depends also i mean the the
skill distribution is something that
taxation theory assumes and it leads to
as it's one of the biggest reasons for
inequality
right like if everyone has all the
resources they need but they still
uh you know and they can basically
fulfill their own utility curve
right then the skill distribution will
lead to a
disturb still in the distribution of
incomes so that's one factor
um the specialization can emerge in
other ways as well
depending on the geometry so you can
imagine that some agents only have
access to stone
the other agents only have access to
wood right and and they basically
understand that they need to specialize
in trading certain resources to each
other for instance
all right um one last simple question
from thomas gilbert uh can agents
communicate
i couldn't tell if emergency specificity
was
pure self-interest introspection or
strategic in a more multi-agent sense
so no communication all right no
teachers or
no yeah but there is some local
observations and local observation
involves
uh when when you're observing that there
is so
you say that you're of like the agents
are observing their local neighborhood
so you mean that
they know about the existence of
resources in the neighborhood
and other agents potentially
the other agents are doing or or not
that much
about the other agents just their
existence
yes they know that an agent is there
they see resources
they can see at our houses okay all
right
okay um good thanks awesome
all right great questions
all right so um just a brief aside on on
simulation so
we're not the first ones to consider
simulations of economies so
there's a rich literature on asian based
modeling where
uh yeah like most of these simulations
are actually quite
simple they typically don't use ai to
the extent that we
have used it um and and what
they very really what abends are really
interested in
is studying immersion phenomena so the
idea is that i would put a lot of agents
very simple interaction rules uh
together like on the right like a lot of
point particles
and uh just like in physics when we have
a lot of simple things but you put
a lot of simple things together and
together they can actually
you know lead to really complex
behaviors
as a group so there's been some
literature
on again using simple abms with optimal
taxation
but again they they typically are much
more simple
and they don't use reinforcement
learning and they don't really explore
the strategic
aspect as much as we do at both the
asian level and at the
taxation level um and
firstly i'll mention that there has been
some uh work by
giannis asel from deepmind and 2018 who
basically also use deep learning
uh to or deep q learning to understand
the tax evasion behavior firms
um and one way to understand it is again
is that that's sort of one-level
reinforcement learning so
um yeah so there's there's some really
interesting work that preceded this
so now let's go to the rl part
um and i'll i'll be brief about this
slide i'll just say that we use
after critic methods so we try to train
parametric policy
both for the agents and for the entity
that are setting taxes in this world
so what does that mean so for the agents
um let's let's look at their objective
function
so agents have different action types
they can build
move around and gather resources
and we can index them with alpha then
there's some skill
so for the if agent and the skill
index by alpha these this agent will
basically earn some money every time it
sort of
does that then the agent also works
so there's different types of labor
associated with every action type
and also the tax denoted capital t
is a number that you know tells the
agent how much
uh it should pay uh in that given state
s
of the environment and together you can
then compute the post tax income
as just skill times labor minus the
taxes that you pay
and this feeds into the utility function
which is a function of post-tax income
and labor so the the the
income part is this power law so ada
here is a constant bigger than zero
and the labor is then subtracted
linearly
and if we in a very simplified cartoon
if you only
have one source of labor you just
connect them all together and make them
one parameter
you can see that the cra function has
this
hill-like behavior so for different
skill levels here
uh you can see that the maximum will
be at different numbers of hours worked
um
so so that's that's another way in which
these agents are basically
differentiated from each other
and then the objective for these agents
is just their
you know typical rl objective for the
reward is the
increase in utility so one thing to note
here is that these
income and labor things are cumulative
over the course of an episode
and so the instantaneous reward is just
how much your total utility
increased that time step
at the same time we have this government
and because this government is going to
set marginal tax rates tau
and these tiles are going to determine
what these capital t
is the full amount of tax the agent each
agent pays
and the planner has a slightly different
objective
so the planner looks at social metrics
like equality and productivity
and again this this reward is the
instantaneous
improvement in these social metrics now
how do you compute that
if we take all the post-tax incomes x
you can compute the so-called gini
coefficient
so the gini coefficient is a normalized
sum
of absolute differences between the
different incomes of all these agents
and then the equality is just one minus
the genie with some
normalization here productivity
is just the sum of all the incomes now
i probably don't have to appreciate the
choir here
i guess but you know the benefit of rl
is that really this objective is
completely flexible
so uh one of the things here
uh is that you know you can have
sustainability
social mobility helping a middle class
anything that you can quantify and put
into a reward function can be put in
here
and given to this government or social
planner as
a optimization objective
another detail here is that this is akin
to a stackelberg game so
that means that over the course of an
episode we can think of it as like a
number of years that are being played
out and at the beginning of each year
the planner first sets the taxes
for that particular year and then the
agents have to play the game
so this is uh just like uh the real
world
now one uh point i want to sort of make
here
is that when we think about multi-agent
learning there's
a lot of related notions in terms of
optimality
for fixed set of reward functions so in
games they're nash equilibria
where basically optimality no agent
wants to unilaterally change the
strategy
and in marcus it's actually there's
something that is uh from a technical
point of view
philosophically the same uh namely the
competitive
global russian equilibrium and you can
think of this as basically
the idea that demand meets supply in a
competitive market that's efficient
another example are auctions where you
can you can you know sell paintings and
you can try to
find some set of rules in this auction
such that
nobody lies about their evaluation
and a bit they bring out for that
particular thing that's being auctioned
off
but if we look at the theory here very
often
the you know the literature tries to
prove some sort of existence or
uniqueness or other properties of these
optimal policies
but it analytically it's very hard to
explicitly describe the optimal policy
and you know in reinforcement we try to
use this strategy to go from a random
policy to the optimal policy as defined
in some way
but the point here is is that these
reward functions are fixed
now on the other hand there's a academic
field called mechanism design and
also called reverse game theory where
the
goal is rather to think about what types
of awards and dynamics
will induce nice equilibria in the
policy space of the agents
for instance you might say well what are
all the reward functions and rules in an
auction such that
all the agents are actually telling the
truth
again the trend here is maybe clear now
that it's often very hard to
finally derive a closed form solution
for
the correct mechanism
and in this context we can think about
the ai economist as actually learning
how to set rewards and therefore it's
learning the optimal mechanism
and simultaneously taking into account
what the
strategy of the agents would be as they
learn to go to optimality under that
mechanism
and a helpful analogy here might be that
you know we can think of gans
where the discriminator also learns to
separate real from fake images by
constantly adjusting the loss function
that is seen by the generator
um and i'll say that that our
collaborator david parks also has
work in this area where he used deep
learning to learn optimum option
mechanisms
but there they didn't use reinforcement
learning so they didn't
look as much at the strategic part where
the agents have to learn
under that mechanism as the mechanism
changes
so one word about income taxes and so
basically taxes work like in the us and
also like in the netherlands i'm from
the netherlands and in both cases work
this works the same
um and in the middle you can see
a depiction of the tax schedule so what
that means that if i make a certain
amount of money
each portion of my income is going to be
taxed at different tax rates
and in the u.s there are seven buckets
so
um we're showing here the income buckets
uh divided by 1000 and these were the
buckets that were
in uh valid in 2018 so for instance if
you made money
between 200 and 4 000 and 510 000
a year then that money in that bucket
would be taxed at
35 and
um yeah it's the same same logic for the
other buckets
so all the models that we considered in
this work
uh basically choose how to set these tax
rates
right but we keep the buckets the same
for all the models
now the the all these agents
both the workers and the social planner
use deep learning so you know we use
neural networks to
take the observation that all these
agents uh had
and then output a set of probabilities
over all the actions that were available
to them
um and this basically hopefully answers
the question that was asked before
so there are different types of
information in this world
so first there's a public map which is
this top down view that we saw before
now the planet can see everything so
where all the resources are and where
all the agents
are but the agents can only see in this
neighborhood around themselves
secondly there's a public state so the
tax rates and the prices in the market
are visible to everyone
and in particular the agents all are
subject to the same taxes so there's no
there's no individualized taxation in
this world
the third category is semi-private
states this means that every agent has a
certain
endowment this means like how much wood
how much stone do i have
and that agent can see that and the
government can see that as well
but other agents cannot see
they cannot see each other's endowment
so that's why it's called semi-private
and then there are also truly private
states that only the agents can see
so only agents can see their own skill
level and how much they've worked how
many hours they've worked
and all this feeds into a pretty
conventional
confnet fully connected layer an lstm
unit and so on
and here's the two level part so the
as i mentioned before we use
reinforcement learning at two different
levels
and at the inner loop we have these
agents that are
observing the state in the world and
they're deciding whether or not they
should
move around buy or sell resources
collect something or build houses and
they
take the tax rates in the world as an
input
and they learn in this inner
reinforcement learning loop
at the same time there's an outer loop
here where
the planner constantly looks at the
state of the world as i just
briefly described and then in its
actions
it's going to adjust the taxes that are
being set in the world
and in particular these taxes then
influence the reward
that these agents see in the inner loop
that makes it too level
now this is a pretty big machine
learning challenge because
as the reward functions change the
optimal behavior under that reward
function
also changes right so in economic terms
if you work this let's say 40 hours a
week you might have made some amount of
money for that
but then as the taxes change you know
the next year
that same amount of work can then give
you less money or more money
and yeah again sorry yeah
yeah just finish the sentence and
oh right yeah let's say that the the
reason
uh that the learning channel learning is
it's an issue
is that there's this constant back and
forth between the social planning and
the agents as they try to adapt to each
other
yeah so sure
a couple of questions here so water
he is uh not sleeping asks uh
whether uh the collected task uh
is the collected tax spent on anything
is that a redistribution of mass or the
taxes just like disappears
equally yeah that's one point i didn't
mention but the total tax that's
collected in a single year
is equally distributed among all the
agents in the world
i guess that's going to impact uh maybe
the outcomes
as well right so if this redistribution
was not
equal but it was based on i don't know
whatever
uh like the needs of the agents uh
then uh maybe i don't know like with who
the results would you expect the results
different
to be different have you looked at that
we have not looked as deeply as
different subsidation
schemes we did try to learn it all the
way in the beginning
but then we found that it's actually
really hard to have a
you know double double the action space
if you will so we
said let's make the subsidy size simpler
so we didn't look too much into
different schemes uh and a different
question from robin chowan uh
he asks whether the spatial
nature of the environment do you expect
it to have a big impact on the results
or not uh have you looked at that
yeah it doesn't have this environment
yeah it does have an impact like there
could be spatial bottlenecks for
instance so
if you're really adversarial you can
block off access to resources to other
agents
um you know the proximity of an agent to
a resource matter so you can use
barriers for instance to restrict access
uh to resources
so the the geometry does matter a lot in
terms of what the agents can actually do
uh and the question from me uh so this
is a game
uh in in many ways and uh
although it's a stacker barrier game
uh i guess uh maybe i'm figuring the
answer as
i say but uh so the agents are acting
uh simultaneously and so if you have
simultaneous action
games then maybe uh you need to
randomize
or whatnot uh so verdi's agents
randomizing and if not
then wouldn't that be you know like
consider or uh
yeah yeah so so the agents here
were sharing weights but they had like
uh different inputs
so to say so the it's a condition
yeah so so the asian model uh they use
the same weights
but with different uh you know inputs in
into their model
because you know they're different it's
like a pom dp if you will
so in a way you're not you're looking
at not the dynamics necessary but
you look at this problem as an
optimization problem
and and you try to uh see
uh what comes up uh
if you are solving this optimization
problem
uh okay uh i see
uh i somehow missed that detail uh
but still the question is whether uh it
would be verse 5 for the agents to
randomize you know in rock paper
scissors
you would randomize because otherwise
you're going to be second guessed by
others
and you're going to lose or maybe this
environment is so complex that it
doesn't really matter
so would you imagine that randomization
would change the nature of the results
uh if we added randomization here
or it wouldn't uh
actually matter it depends on
randomization in what sense
if you randomized
your individual actions right i see
um i think in this particular
environment
the the driver for specialization is so
strong
like there's such a clear benefit
of you know specialization information
about yourself using your actions and
also thinking about
with the text right so you could
randomize a little bit show that you are
lamer than what you are
and uh i don't know
yeah and then
i think that that's a really interesting
thing like i guess we haven't really
observed that agents learn to
create uncertainty for the planner or
something like that to be better off
um right that's something that we
haven't really seen um
i think the dynamics are such that just
the again the urge to maximize utility
right leads such leads to such a strong
advantage to these agents
to do one thing that basically that
doesn't doesn't seem to occur
in this particular setting but i don't
you know maybe for more complicated
settings that does become interesting
for the agents
yeah and one final quick question uh
so the hotel loop uh that involves the
government
is that working on a slower time scale
or
same time scale like adaptation rate for
yes it's a slower time scale because the
uh
basically there's a task year so one if
you remember the episode was 1 000 times
steps
so there are 10 years of 100 steps each
and a planner acts once every year
and the agents act 100 times every year
so the time skills are different
great that's it
thanks great so
what do you see if you actually run this
well this is a very characteristic
uh behavior so we see four
uh social welfare curves uh in the top
so the ai commas is in green and then
the other baselines are in
blue red and purple so the social
welfare is equality
times productivity and you see that
what's happening here is that the system
starts out
with some pre-trained agents and then
the planner also starts to learn so all
these models start off from the same
initial level of social welfare but then
if we look at the ai economist
we see that the social welfare actually
does not just
monotonically increase we see that it
actually goes up
and it goes back down again and then you
know it rises again
now the reason for this is that these
agents in the beginning don't actually
know how to respond to taxes so in the
beginning there's a sort of
exploit that the planet can find but
then the agents start to adapt and then
we just this back and forth dynamic
kicks in
so we see that this is a very
characteristic type of behavior for
this two level learning setup
you can see that the other the red and
the purple don't really suffer from this
and then the blue
curve does seem to have a little bit of
that and i'll explain in a second why
that is
and you can see the same sort of trend
for productivity and equality
separately
so how do you go about mitigating this
instability
we found that there are a couple things
that are useful
and a lot of other things don't seem to
work as well
so the first one is that you do
two-phase training so as i mentioned
you first train your agents in an
environment without any taxes
so fix reward functions and then you
start to train the planner after the
agents have converged into the in the
first phase
the second thing is curriculum learning
so the agents
slowly uh see the cost of uh
work increase in phase one and then the
planner
slowly increases the taxes over time and
this is just to
ensure that the reward function is not
too
penalizing at the beginning of each
phase and the third thing is entropy
regularization
so this is very common but we found that
you need to actually carefully tune
these entropies and especially
relative to each other to make sure that
the agents explore enough and don't give
up
prematurely because they see a big
penalty because of taxes that might be
too high in some episode
now i see i'm probably a bit short on
time so i'll skip this i'll just say
that
there's a rich literature and
multi-agent learning that is
particularly
relevant to what we've done um but i'll
take a time i'll skip this and actually
go to the results
so here's a side-by-side comparison of
these
two environments that have different
taxes on the left
there's a free market no taxes at all
and we see that the social welfare here
goes to 1258
and the pie in the middle shows you how
welfare or the wealth is distributed in
this world so we see that the dark blue
agent builds a lot of houses and he gets
about two-thirds of all the
wealth in this economy and the size of
the pie also grows
proportional to the amount of total
income the productivity on the right we
see the ai economist
which data gets much higher social
welfare but also the distribution of
wealth is more equal so the dark blue
asian for instance get just
just over half of the wealth in this
world and we see that
in aggregate this ai economist actually
system
consistently improves this social
welfare over all the baselines
so if we compare to the sas model it
improves 16
uh that's when it's boxed on the right
and then even more compared to the other
uh models the free market and the us
federal taxes
so for the purple bar we just use the
tax rates as set in 2018.
um i will explain in a bit and where the
blue uh one comes from
and the other uh graphs here show you
that if we look at productivity the free
market is actually the most productive
people you know in total society makes
the most money
but it's actually very unequal so if you
turn on taxes
you will hurt productivity but you
actually improve equality and that
together leads to higher social welfare
in the end
here's a visualization so what do these
tax models actually look like
in purple you see they use federal taxes
so it's a progressive scheme so
tax rates go up as you make more money
then in blue
there's a sas formula where taxes
actually go down in this particular
setup
and then the ai economist actually
learns something that's qualitatively
different
it looks more like a w or
a u so the taxes are high in the
beginning
then they're low in the middle and then
they're high again at the top
i'll say that here the tax rates are
actually an average because again there
are 10
years in a simulation so but this
pattern here is quite consistent
on the right you can see that this
slightly different tax
schedule actually leads to higher
subsidies so
um on the right you can see how much
money each agent
has to pay after also taking the
subsidies into account
so negative means that you get money and
you see that the
under the green points here the agents
on average get
more or the lower skilled agents get
more than under the other
tax schemes and again the tax money
that's collected by the government is
redistributed equally each year
now one word on how you get the blue
line again i won't go
for all the details is because of time
but the way
the blue lines is created is by
following the recipe given by syaz in
this 2001 paper on awful non-linear
taxes
so the idea there is is that you can
derive this closed form formula for the
marginal tax rates
again it's a fraction and the g
and alpha here are basically parameters
of the income distribution
in the world and also a function of the
so-called social welfare weights small g
and the e here is the elasticity so
elasticity if you might remember
is the sensitivity of a worker to a
change in the tax rate
and if you compute all these things so
you can estimate g
alpha and e all from the data that you
get in the simulation
you end up with this a regressive tax
schedule
now it turns out that in economics
this elasticity is actually the key
player
this is actually one of the most
important parameters that people try to
estimate
so in a nutshell elasticity is basically
how much
the income changes when i change the tax
rate so it's like
formally speaking this differential and
one way of estimating this uh this this
e
is basically by doing an ordinary least
squares on a rolling data set of income
and tax pairs that we've observed in the
simulation
so you can derive that there's this
linear relationship between
uh the log incomes and the log taxes and
this elasticity is basically the slope
of this of this curve and what you get
is that like
um the elasticity is somewhere between
point eight or free
and there are other methods actually to
estimate this and then these are
fed into the sas tax
um so finally
what's so interesting about this is that
we've seen that this ai economy does
actually pretty well
um but this is despite the fact that
these ai agents actually learn to be
strategic
right these rl agents don't like to pay
taxes that actually reduces their
utility
just like in real life and so they find
these strategies
that allow them to pay less tax over the
course of an episode
in particular you know one of these
agents has learned that
if you report high and low incomes
alternatingly
then you actually get a lower tax burden
over 10 again over the course of an
episode
and all the baselines that we uh just
mentioned
actually don't account for these kinds
of temporal strategies for instance in
the sas framework
the economy is supposed to be static and
so that means that people would not be
able to
execute these kinds of temporal
strategies basically the framework just
simply does not allow for that
and again you need to make that
assumption because otherwise you cannot
actually derive
analytical tasks formula
um okay so we also tested this out with
real people
so we asked okay maybe quickly
we have two questions uh yes uh booths
are
uh concerning equality and the way
you're measuring it
uh so how did you uh so first of all
there was some graph uh results uh where
you were showing
uh something uh related to productivity
and equality together
how was that defined was it the state
forward sum
or yeah like that that graph uh over
there yeah this is the bad chart
productivity is just the income defined
before
uh i think we understood that uh the
next uh
uh there was a bad chat uh
that somehow they were together uh i
think it's
further down uh yeah here
yeah equality times productivity it's
the the
the product uh which is uh being
optimized by uh
government here right yes
yes so i guess uh
the question was like how do you justify
that you take the product
uh because that is going to lead to some
point on the pareto front but
like why why the product there right
um yeah i mean it's a choice i mean it's
intuitively
it's the function that um
increases right as both equality and
productivity increase right so
on the preview front basically um to go
towards the preview front like you know
you can follow equal advanced
productivity
um but you guys right so you can
combine equality and productivity in
many different ways
such that that is monotonic in
in each individual component
that's right and so we just chose this
because
it's simple um it it works so to say
um we could have we we've tried other
variations of this
but we didn't really see qualitatively
different
like things and again the point of the
paper is to show that
for a given social welfare definition
you can do this technique and
find interesting solutions that are
better but yeah but we couldn't we
tried other ones as well um we just
didn't have time for that
so another question was uh
so where these qualitative trends are
robust to changing the measure of
equality
have you tried any other measures of
equality
uh not the genie in there we chose uh
the genie index because it's a widely
accepted economic metric
um we haven't really looked into other
definitions
and the mysterious question have you
ever looked at
how uh ai economists are like this whole
model would respond
to shocks that uh
like the 2008 financial crisis are just
now
what we're experiencing this year
discovery
that's a great question um yeah i i we
we didn't look too much into that but i
think that's certainly that's one of the
things that's so
fascinating about this what would happen
if we consider harder mdps if you will
all right uh whoa okay
lots of more questions uh
okay uh thomas gilbert asked conceptual
question do we have to assume the pareto
curve is fully deterministic
uh i'm not sure what that means the w
shape proposed by the
ai economist could instead be
interpreted as suggesting four five
distinct
positive thresholds for public policy
interventions which is specific trade
union protection arbitration
rather than strict cut-ups for utility
optimization achieve marginal tax
tax rates this might imply more than one
social welfare
definition okay
i sort of um
i i didn't completely cash the question
i guess i guess the the the point was
can we interpret this cash schedule and
use this as inspiration
for a slightly different way to employ
taxes
uh i'm not really sure if that was the
point
yeah it's not anti-clear to me uh but
looking at the solution
of uh ai economies this this w shaped
curve
uh i'm thinking about that maybe some
people wouldn't like
uh to see such a curve so
uh but at the same time if uh
so i kind of find it interesting that uh
if you said uh set the
goal as as you did to optimize this
overall measure
uh which was uh this product of uh
equality and productivity uh then you
end up with a solution like this
the question is whether if you would
constrain
uh the tax curve to something like
monotonically increasing that people
would think
is a priority more fair uh
would that uh lead to a verse uh
solution in terms of this measure have
you tried
uh to impose any such restrictions while
doing the optimization and like
would it be worse why to to try doing
something like this
we didn't try uh having a neural network
predict part of the you know the you
know some structural constraint or
having some structural constraint we
didn't really try that
um i think it would be interesting to
see but in a way
right the the divergence like this
sorry so do you do you think that
uh there would be a fundamental limit to
what you can achieve if the
the curve was monotonic or was it just
like oh this is one of the solutions
that we have found and like
fine uh but maybe there are multiple
solutions who knows uh maybe there are
even better solutions a complex system
right
yeah and i think that that's just a
thing that requires more investigation
in a way i think that the nice thing
about this is that you don't need to
have any sort of priors
on what good and bad tax looks like
right you just let the rl agent just
figure out what it wants to do and then
you see what happens
um i guess good explaining it to uh
the lay person uh if you get a curve
like this
exactly and especially very good
politician too
uh to be able to do that
right so i think that yeah i will get to
that like later um but i think that's
actually where
a really interesting line of future work
lies right is that
on the one hand there's human priors
about fairness and and what fair
should look like right and then there is
basically how you get there right what's
what does the policy look like
and then sort of like repeat i think
what i said in the beginning the goal
here is that we want to focus the
discussion more around
what are the goals and constraints in
society right
and then we just let the ai just find a
solution
and then as long as we're happy with the
goals and constraints then you know
then whatever happens happens right in a
way that's sort of a
one way to think about it although i
yeah there's a lot of like ifs and buts
but yeah i mean
lots of caveats uh interim stuff whether
we are
able to write down the objective that we
would later not regret
writing down if we you know just let
things happen
uh but i think it's great uh
okay i think that all the uh questions
were answered
okay great i do want to get two things
across so i'll just
i'll be quick about this section uh we
did try this
in a simulation uh by this i mean a
simpler version of the simulation
uh with but then with real people
controlling the agents and making real
money so every house would actually give
people
10 cents and so on and we found that
actually there is a
another solution that you can find with
the ai economist it actually transfers
well to this simulation with people
so if you look at the performance in
social welfare you'll find that the
economist outperforms the baselines but
with a
bigger variance in the results and
that's because basically people are not
as consistent as
ai agents they're much more adversarial
they block people
and so the outcomes in human studies
tend to be much
higher variance than with ai agents but
still there's this trend
uh where the ai economist does well
here's a different metric it also shows
this so um
inverse income weighted utility is just
a weighted average of all the utilities
of agents in this world
and on that metric the aircraft also
does better
and again there are a lot of details
here but i'll refer for
all the details to the paper
so the final point i wanted to make is
that
the future uh if you will and uh
again economics is not a discipline
that's actually using a lot of ai
uh they're just starting to appreciate
the the benefit of
these tools and so we hope that uh
this this work shows them uh that
reinforcement is actually a very
powerful tool to design economic
policies in very complicated
economic scenarios but before we can
actually use this in the real world
we will still have to do a lot more work
right we have to improve the fidelity
simulation
we have to incorporate mobile data we
have to think about how you would
actually
use the policy discovered by ai in the
real world
and to your point sava how would you
encode social values into reward
functions
it's not very clear what the right way
is on the other hand for
ai researchers we hope that this work is
a motivator to look more into these
types of social welfare issues and
there's
really interesting technical depth to
this to this problem
um and you know some of the things you
can think about is that how you do you
actually do
efficient and consistent two-level
reinforcement learning and we've seen
the curves goes up
up and down um how do you deal with a
reality gap where this simulation
actually
is not the same thing as the real world
how do you then still
manage to transfer policy well to the
real world
how do you explain economic policies
right a really big thing is that if
somebody has to pay twice as much tax
under the ai economist
how do you explain that like why is that
why is that happening
and then there are also many multi-asian
dynamics like cooperation
coordination so on partial information
all these things are ingredients
in this economic setting as well and
finally
when we do this type of reinforcing
learning
we might imagine that you want to do
safe exploration and not violate any
sort of ethical constraints for instance
or understand
again how you encode them and make sure
that the policy that you end up with
does not
actually violate those constraints that
we've set and these
still remain open areas for future
research
and i'll close out by saying that we
open sourced our code for the economic
simulation
the first version so you can go to
github and take a look
uh we also have a public slack channel
an email address so if you have any
questions you're absolutely welcome to
join us and just chat with us there
we are also organizing a workshop on
machine learning for economic policy at
nurbs this year
so this website machine learning for
economicpolicy.com is all the details
and we basically are asking more broadly
how machine learning can help develop
more effective economic policies
how can we build better simulations that
reflect the real world in a better way
and with a great lineup of speakers here
i won't go for all of them but it's
phenomenal speakers and i'm super happy
that we
have uh gotten the opportunity to
organize this
so um if you're interested please join
us there
and also i'll do a small plug for my
collaborator david parks
so he is hiring a postdoc also to
work in this area again to explore some
of the questions that i alluded to
before so if you're interested you can
contact david parks directly
or go to his website where he has all
the details on this postdoc
so that was the last bit if you want to
know more there is a website that we
have
where we again talk about the research
directions that we think are super
interesting
um the papers here and yeah if you have
any questions feel free to
shoot me an email and i'm happy to take
questions now
i'll stop there
awesome thank you uh
so in the meanwhile robin asked the
question robin sean
uh do you think it would work well uh it
would work as well if the social planner
was formulated as a bandit agent instead
of a full rl
or why not uh
i think it's probably worse because
we've seen that the agents have these
these temporal policies right like you
see that an agent can lower its tax
burden
by going uh you know different
you know having different incomes
working different numbers of hours every
year
and i my intuition here is is that
keeping track of that history uh lets
the planner
adapt better to those kinds of temporal
strategies i i
my guess is it's harder to you know
encode it in a contextual band for
instance
um but yeah
it's like you need to really see the
pattern over time over many years
um so yeah i had that related question
of
uh did you add any exploration
uh for the agents to you know
explode a little bit are is it all
greedy
what's happening just an optimization
that is happening we added entry
regularization to
both the agents and the planner so it's
all on policy so we just sample from the
learning policy and yeah there
there's no special exploration tricks
other than entropy
the exploration needs i see okay
yeah makes sense uh
it's uh very inspiring uh yeah there was
one more question i think you partly
answered that
which was uh
about whether uh you can
imagine some scenarios where you could
ethically
uh deploy something like this in the
real world
uh so you know like how do
how do we make the next step and like i
guess you're proposing that
maybe uh we should we could use ai
uh for uh optimizing society
various aspects of it and i really like
this idea
uh but there are of course a lot of
ethical questions that come up
uh and uh so i guess uh the person who
asked the question was wondering about
have you
considered the ethical implications of
uh
deploying uh something like this in the
real world
yeah that's a great sec my backup slide
on ethics
yes we have considered that we actually
have a an ethical review
in our archive uh paper uh where
we we did talk with a number of
academics and and other researchers
about this
um yeah there you know there are a lot
of concerns that you could have
because we're talking about real people
and their economic welfare and so on
um yeah so so definitely uh that's a big
thing
i think we have to think very carefully
and and
and also talk with economists and policy
experts and other people that
you know the policy would apply to right
um
and and yeah i think i think it's it's
gonna be a very
um careful discussion that we need to
have
but i think we think it's worth it um
but we do have that fx review where we
talk about
um you know what if you have biased data
that you fit a simulation to
um what if taxes are not anonymized
right what if taxes are
actually use your name as an input is
that fair and how do you even detect
that if that's happening right like that
it's very unclear uh right now so yeah
and i'll just say
um the paper has a lot more detail on
that
but it's super so there is a technical
interesting technical point by
uh uh he is asking
uh whether we could maybe model the
interactions between the agents
uh using winfield theory
and so instead of being local the
problem would become this
mean field game
uh which we could possibly imagine
solving analytically
or numerically and and this would you
know potentially change the outcomes
uh have you thought about any such
formulations uh
at all yeah that's super interesting i
thought about it yes uh done it no
um but i think that that's yeah there's
a great
line of research there as well um on on
simplifying the multi-agent problem
right um
there's yeah like if there's there's
france oligue
um there's uh i think shimon watson um
there are a bunch of papers that have
appeared in the past years actually it's
a very old subject like
i think peter soon hog one of the papers
that i quoted in my slides has valid
decomposition
networks which also thinks about how do
you
how do you make the problem simpler
right by by assuming some structure in a
queue function or other ways of
you know assume something about locality
and all these things yeah and
i think that's super interesting we just
haven't had time yet to
try it out okay
good
i don't see any any other questions and
we are a little bit past time
uh so i think we should let people go
uh but thank you so much for for the
talk it was super interesting
uh for me for sure and excited to
see more work on this in the future
thank you yeah thanks so much for having
me this was really fun
a lot of great questions so i hope that
i
gave an appropriate answer and if not
you can always email us
at um the email address i'll if i feel
okay i'll flash it briefly here
you can always email us and
i don't know i can send you the discord
i don't want to overload you with
anything but i can
send you the address of the discord
server maybe you can log in and then
if there are further questions then you
could answer those
uh later on i don't know um
absolutely yeah if you sent that i will
join now and
um you know if anyone has questions i'm
happy to answer
yeah fantastic uh thank you again
[Music]
thank you all right i'll see you in
discord yep